we all are going to die one day we know
that to me that is like jumping in the
ocean everyone is running towards the
ocean and they're going to jump in the
ocean we need to put on a life vest for
them convince them somehow that you need
to put on this vest then you
jump brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give 10 p in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing G that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends I start this video with sad news
of uh our young beautiful brother Subhan
Allah who was I would say nearly an
identical twin of Muti M uh I could even
see from his facial expressions the way
he SP speaks uh the way his facial
expressions were the way he mov eyebrows
like he was really really trying to
imitate M may Allah bless and preserve
him mu Yak was a young Brother 17 years
old uh at the age of 20 in the morning
today morning early hours of today after
an illness he passed away if you there's
so much things to take from this he's
somebody that met
mu here we finally meet with
the how are you
I'm doing well alhamdulillah so lovely
to meet you and see you for the first
time mashallah I have heard and I have
watched and now we Meet Mah
alhamdulillah nice to meet you too may
Allah Grant you goodness and I pray that
the people can benefit Mah from this
young
man um he spoke with him alhamdulillah
and you know he's a beautiful person
studying in Egypt if I'm not mistaken
and what does this tell us brother and
sisters it shows us that Subhan Allah
any of us any any second any matter for
that time can pass away we have this
perception as human beings as if we are
going to live like we are never going to
die we the only creatures that we act
and behave and we're under this false
delusion that just because we wake up
every morning that we're going to wake
up the next morning so the thing is that
we don't really understand that death
can be WR written and has been written
for any of us at any time and this
illnesses car Crush heart attack kidney
failure this failure is all excuses that
was your time to die that was the kidney
failure was an excuse the cack was an
excuse that accident was an excuse we
know of people who just have a little
mind of fall and they die it's just a
mere excuse guys and one thing that we
can take from this is what go to a
social media what do we learn from this
many people when they pass away their
family members are doing what take down
their Instagram take down their Facebook
take down their Twitter take down their
Snapchat take down their YouTube videos
why because they did nothing beneficial
rather it's going to be something that
is going to harm them in the hereafter
they are too excuse me busy and occupied
of what cover the shame cover the sin
cover the a yes for the brothers yes
going topless yeah I'm not going to
mention sisters I'm going to mention
Brothers yes Brothers doing Haram
showing the a doing all this kind of
stuff aldah yes oh Mah okay and then
we've got the sisters as well the
sisters who are covering their um their
husband's faces covering their husband's
a and showing their amazing brilliant
Subhan Allah your your your whole body
is an a at least a man Subhan Allah
there is you are covering your husband's
face and showing yourself and
beautifying yourself Subhan Allah
brother and sisters yeah so the thing is
here that what's going to happen is the
following his social media is the
prophet said every action or everything
when the son of Adam dies comes to an
end except three things number
one something that is an ongoing charity
it can be a tree that benefits the
people the children the animals a mosque
a Masjid a a um whatever you name it
okay A a look what we do guided prayer M
that we we teach people how to for a
orphanage whatever the second thing the
prophet said is beneficial knowledge
that you teach the beneficial knowledge
that you teach others your children ex
whoever it is for that matter as that
carries on it is and number three a
righteous child making Dua for you so
Subhan Allah when we go to a social
media account do we go and say oh my
gosh let's get rid of this no we say
alhamdulillah how can we promote this
how can we push this more how can we
make sure so much people benefit from it
because there is nothing nothing to be
ashamed of please please acknowledge
that why because my dear sisters you
don't want to be the last the first time
you ever wear hijab is when you are dead
and the same and and for the brothers
yeah what is the action that you're
doing brother when's the action when is
the last time you are going to argument
say oppress people or your your tongue
is safe from people when you die when
you're quiet then when you're dead
people are going to say alhamdulillah we
are free from this man's evil is this
the first time that people are going to
be alhamdulillah he's dead that we are
free from his evil and his csing and his
biting and is lying alhamdulillah
imagine so I ask Allah subhana to Grant
him the highest rank of Jen and I urge
you guys to please share something from
his videos insh that's beneficial in and
let it be a for him and may Allah accept
his deeds and Grant him the highest
ranks of J imagine he's now witnessing
the things that he said he's seeing the
Unseen imagine Subhan Allah brothers and
sisters that that amazing amazing moment
where you have meet you are meeting your
lord the angels will come out what to
them come out to the mercy of your lord
good words good titles are going to be
given to you and you're going to be in
your grave jna Gardens of Jenna when
you're resurrected aldah Allah says they
shall not grieve nor shall they fear
they shall not grieve nor shall they
fear if you put Allah first and make him
number one you will not grieve nor you
shall fear and may Allah subhana tala
Grant him the highest ranks of Jenna and
forgive him for his shortcomings that's
all I wanted to say